buffet
de respecter le délai madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la proposition que
je vous présente aujourd'hui est en
réalité de caractère très modeste pas de
grandes ambitions très loin évidemment
de viser la refonte du régime électoral
applicable aux élections sénateuriales
et là pour seul objectif précis de
remédier à des difficultés constatées à
l'occasion du dernier scrutin du mois de
septembre 2020 comme vous le savez la
loi du décembre 2019
issu de la proposition de loi de notre
collègue Alain Richard ici présent à
étendu aux élections des sénateurs
l'ensemble des règles applicables en
matière de propagande électorale aux
autres scrutins cette loi est entrée en
vigueur en juin 2020 si bien que les
élections du 27 septembre 2020 ont vu le
renouvellement de la série 2 des
sénateurs ont été les premiers ont été
arrêtés par le premier scrutin concerné
par son application
ce scrutin a toutefois révélé deux types
de difficultés liées à la mise en oeuvre
de la loi de 2019 et plus précisément à
l'application aux élections sénatoriales
des interdictions posées dans les
dispositions des articles L49 et l502-2
du code électoral ces deux articles
interdisent d'une part de mener tout
action de propagande la veille ainsi que
le jour du scrutin et d'autre part de
communiquer les résultats de l'élection
en métropole avant la fermeture du
dernier bureau de vote sur le territoire
métropolitain or l'application de ces
dispositions s'est révé les
problématiques dans le cas des élections
signatoriales qui sont les seules
élections où peuvent avoir lieu deux
tours de scrutin évidemment le même jour
dans les circonscriptions l'élection se
déroule au scrutin majoritaire le
premier tour de scrutin est ainsi ouvert
de 8h30 à 11h tandis que le second est
ouvert le cas échéant naturellement de
15h30 à 17h30 en conséquence
l'application de la première disposition
mentionnée les candidats qualifiés pour
le second tour se sont trouvés dans
l'impossibilité de faire campagne entre
les deux tours de scrutin par ailleurs
l'embargo sur les résultats qui a été
imposé jusqu'à la fermeture du dernier
bureau de vote sur le territoire
métropolitain soit 17h30 est apparu en
totale contradiction avec la nécessité
de communiquer les résultats du premier
tour de scrutin dès la fin de la matinée
ou en tout état de cause avant
l'ouverture du second tour de scrutin
c'est pourquoi la proposition que je
vous présente prévoit que les deux
dispositions de droit commun évoquées
relatives à la propagande et la
communication d'un résultat ne
s'applique pas aux élections
sénatoriales naturelles plus précisément
l'interdiction de mener des actions de
propagande pour les candidats à
l'extension à l'élection sénatoriale
pardon serait levé uniquement pour la
période de l'entre-deux-tours dans les
départements concernés par le seul
scrutin majoritaire et l'embargo sur le
résultat tel qu'il est prévu par le
droit commun serait quant à lui purement
supprimer pour l'ensemble des
départements afin que les résultats des
premiers tours de scrutins puissent être
à nouveau communiqué dès la fin de
matinée de plus les résultats des
seconds tours de scrutin et ceux des
scrutin à la représentation
proportionnelle pour être à nouveau être
diffusé sur l'ensemble du territoire
métropolitain de façon progressive au
fur et à mesure de leur remonter depuis
les départements par ces deux
aménagements le texte proposé vise ainsi
à garantir je le crois le bon
déroulement des élections sénatoriales à
venir naturellement madame la ministre
l'objectif est qu'elle puisse
s'appliquer au prochain scrutin du mois
de septembre 2023 et de ce fait nous
comptons bien sûr sur une inscription
rapide dans la mesure le texte sera
adopté ici je n'ai pas trop de doute a
priori alors du jour de l'Assemblée
nationale dès le mois de janvier
prochain mais celui dulier doit nous
donner son avis merci
merci donc la parole est à notre
rapporteur monsieur le rue dullier pour
ici environ 5 minutes
merci madame le Président Madame la
ministre monsieur le Président cher
François Noël mes chers collègues comme
la démontré le président François Noel
buffet la proposition de loin donc il
est l'auteur vise en fait un objectif
très clair et circonscrit il s'agit de
remédier aux difficultés constatées lors
du scrutin sénatorial de septembre 2020
s'agissant des publications des
résultats d'une part et de la propagande
électorale d'autre part je n'ai nul
besoin je pense de m'attarder sur les
problèmes soulevés par l'application aux
élections sénatoriales de ces deux
dispositions de droit commun mentionnés
par le président buffet
dans les départements concernés par le
scrutin majoritaire qui sont au nombre
de 34 lors du renouvellement de
septembre 2020
l'embargo sur les résultats imposés
jusqu'à 17h30 est en effet apparu peu
compatibles avec la nécessité de
communiquer les résultats du premier
tour dès la fin de matinée cette embargo
c'est également relevé difficile à
respecter dans les départements
concernés par le scrutin proportionnel
en dépit des actions d'information
menées spécialement à cette fin par le
ministère de l'Intérieur et par le Sénat
lui-même des fuites ont pu être
constatées avant 17h30 de la part de
site internet de réseau sociaux ainsi
que d'organes de presse locale ces
derniers étaient en effet peu habitués à
diffuser
était habitué pardon à diffuser
progressivement les résultats ce qui
était la norme
le scrutin de 2020 c'est pourquoi il
apparaît pertinent de rétablir la
possibilité de communiquer les résultats
en métropole dès la proclamation des
résultats et indépendamment du fait que
des bureaux de vote soient encore
ouverts dans d'autres départements
métropolitains ainsi le retour au
principe d'une diffusion des résultats
au fil de l'eau est à la fois
indispensable dans les départements
concernés par le scrutin majoritaire
mais également bienvenue dans les
départs départements concernés par le
scrutin proportionnel le deuxième axe de
cette proposition de loi et sur le fait
qu'il était moins incongru d'interdire
aux candidats qualifiés pour le second
tour de faire campagne durant les
quelques heures qui séparent la clôture
du premier tour
de l'ouverture du second en visant à
permettre de déroger pour la seule
période de l'entre-deux-tours un
interdiction posée par l'article L49
l'article premier de la proposition de
loin apparaît comme une mesure de bon
sens les candidats qualifiés pour le
second tour serait donc à nouveau
autorisé à distribuer des tracts envoyer
des messages ou encore tenir des
réunions électorales à ce moment là je
souhaite souligner que cette mesure ne
remettrait nullement en cause
l'interdiction de mener des actions de
propagande durant la journée de samedi
ainsi que le dimanche le matin du
dimanche de l'élection elle ne
remettrait pas davantage en question
l'interdiction d'introduire tardivement
des éléments nouveaux de polémique
électorale qui est posée par l'article
l48-2 du code électoral par ailleurs
le rétablissement de la possibilité pour
les candidats de faire campagne entre
les deux tours de scrutin pose également
la question du financement des dépenses
à Visé électorale qui seraient engagées
durant cette période comme vous le savez
les règles relatives au financement et
au plafonnement des dépenses électorales
prévues pour les élections législatives
départementales ou encore municipales
s'appliquent également aux élections
sénatoriales les candidats à ces
élections ayant réalisé au moins 1% des
suffrages exprimés doivent déposer
auprès de la Commission nationale des
comptes de campagne et des financements
publics leurs comptes retraçant
l'ensemble des recettes perçues et
l'ensemble des dépenses engagées en vue
d'élection les candidats ayant obtenu au
moins 5% des suffrages exprimés peuvent
ensuite prétendre sous certaines
conditions bien évidemment au
remboursement forfaitaire de la part de
l'État ainsi conformément à l'article
52-4 du code électoral seuls les engagée
au vu de l'élection et antérieure à la
date du à la date du tour de scrutin où
elle a été acquise est inscrite au
compte de campagne peuvent être
considérés par la Commission nationale
des comptes de campagne et des
financement public comme des dépenses
électorales et donc par conséquent être
éligible au remboursement forfaitaire de
l'État en toute trigger ne sont donc pas
concernés des dépenses intervenant le
jour même de l'élection
avant l'entrée en vigueur de la loi tous
les deux décembre 2019 la Commission
nationale des comptes de campagne et
financement public admettaient à titre
exceptionnel que les dépenses liées à
l'organisation de réception avec les
grands électeurs dans l'entre-deux tours
ou encore l'envoi de message durant
cette même période pouvait être
qualifiée d'électorales cette position
procéder d'un ajustement de la doctrine
classique de la CNCCFP et d'un écart par
rapport à la lettre de l'article 52-4 du
code électoral ainsi depuis l'entrée en
vigueur de la loi du 2 décembre 2019 les
dépenses liées aux actions de propagande
entreprises entre les deux tours du
scrutin et qui sont inscrites au compte
de campagne du candidat présente donc un
caractère irrégulier et ne peuvent pas
donc faire l'objet d'un quelconque
remboursement de la part de l'État
en toute logique l'adoption de cette
présente loi proposition de loi les
vrais pour la période de
l'entre-deux-tours de l'élection
sénatoriale l'interdiction posée par
l'article L49 du code électoral si bien
que la position de la Commission
nationale des comptes de campagne
admettant le remboursement des dépenses
de propagande intervenues entre les deux
tours du scrutin serait à nouveau
susceptible de s'appliquer pour autant
il n'apparaît pas à satisfaisant
notamment au regard de l'objectif de
sécurité juridique de faire dépendre
l'éligibilité des dépenses engagées par
les candidats aux élections sénatoriales
durant cette période d'entre-deux-tours
de la seule prise de position de la
cncfp c'est pourquoi je vous proposerai
tout à l'heure un amendement qui adapte
la rédaction de l'article
52-4 du code électoral à la spécificité
du scrutin sénatorial l'objectif étant
de garantir sans ambiguïté les
éligibilité au remboursement des
dépenses engagées entre les deux tours
de scrutin lorsque ceux-ci ont lieu le
même jour enfin comme la rappeler à
juste titre le président buffet cette
proposition de loin à vocation à entrer
en vigueur avant la prochaine échéance
électorale de septembre 2023 les délais
impartis sont donc relativement serrés
et en tout état de cause inférieur au
délai d'un an que la même loi du 2
décembre 2019 avait posé comme durée
minimale à respecter entre la
modification des règles électorales et
les élections concernées le législateur
est toutefois libre de déroger au cas
par cas cette règle en l'espèce une
telle dérogation semble justifier par
conséquent je vous proposerai d'adopter
cette proposition de loi ainsi modifier
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur maintenant
la parole est à Madame la Ministre s'il
vous plaît
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président
Monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je tiens tout
d'abord à saluer la mission essentielle
que remplie votre commission sous votre
conduite chers François Noël buffet pour
la bonne administration de notre pays
c'est la première fois que nous nous
rencontrons dans ce cadre je vous dis à
l'aune des nouvelles fonctions qui m'ont
été confiées combien j'attache
d'importance à la qualité de nos
relations au service des collectivités
des territoires et des citoyens je crois
profondément au dialogue à la
possibilité de s'accorder sur les
meilleurs compromis à la nécessité de
dégager des consensus
et je pense que cette proposition de loi
qui nous a été présentée nous en sorte
nous en offre d'ores et déjà une très
bonne occasion elle porte bien sûr sur
un sujet sensible car touchant à la
mécanique même de notre démocratie mais
elle se fondent aussi sur un constat que
nous partageons tous celui du caractère
inadéquat des modifications de 2019 avec
les particularités du scrutin sénatorial
dans notre pays notamment dans les
départements concernés par le scrutin
majoritaire à deux tours c'est pourquoi
notre gouvernement porte un avis
favorable sur l'ensemble des
dispositions de cette proposition de loi
elle permettront de lever l'interdiction
de la communication de résultats avant
la fermeture du dernier bureau de vote
sur le territoire métropolitain ainsi
que de faire campagne entre les deux
tours des sénatoriales lorsque cela est
applicable ce sont des mesures de bon
sens qui permettent de corriger les
difficultés et les ambiguïtés constatées
lors de la première mise en œuvre de ces
modifications à l'occasion du scrutin de
la communication des résultats dans les
départements à scrutin majoritaire dont
le premier tour avait été conclusif
avait été longuement repoussé jusqu'à la
fin de la journée alors même que les
résultats fuientaient déjà dans les
médias
et par ailleurs l'impossibilité de faire
campagne entre les deux tours avait
présenté le risque de remettre en cause
de la sécurité juridique des élections
sénatoriales comme a pu le montrer la
jurisprudence récente du Conseil
constitutionnel en définitive l'objectif
qui est recherché de rendre aux
élections sénatoriales les dispositions
qui sont les mieux adaptées à leur
spécificités donc aux réalités de nos
territoires
pour la levée de l’interdiction de la
communication de résultats nous n'avons
aucune réserve puisqu'il n'y a pas de
risque de créer un précédent pour
d'autres types de scrutins pour la levée
de l'interdiction de faire campagne
entre les deux tours une difficulté doit
être prise en compte à mon sens rendre
inapplicable l'article 49 du code
électoral ne doit pas conduire à une
politisation excessive de
l'entre-deux-tours afin de préserver la
neutralité du vote c'est pourquoi nous
proposons de reconduire les
recommandations antérieures de mesures
et de retenue pour les candidats au
niveau infra réglementaires comme
c'était le cas auparavant mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je crois que ces
ajustements techniques sont les
bienvenus à l'horizon du prochain
scrutin sénatorial et je suis convaincu
qu'il susciteront une large adhésion des
sénatrices et des sénateurs au-delà de
tout débat passionnel
c'est une proposition de loi qui va dans
le sens de l'intérêt général de notre
démocratie et de la juste prise en
compte des caractéristiques du Sénat
chambre des territoires je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre je vais donc
ouvrir maintenant la discussion générale
madame cukkerman madame Goulet et
Monsieur Marc madame kukerman oui merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
salut également à notre collègue
rapporteur et l'auteur président de la
commission des lois de cette proposition
de loi qui effectivement et je crois que
l'auteur l'a rappelé avec beaucoup
d'humilité ne vise pas à reposer la
question dans son ensemble de
l'organisation des élections
sanatoriales de la pertinence ou non de
deux séries de la pertinence ou non de
deux types de scrutins le même jour
selon la taille du département
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
rapporteur de la difficulté qu'il y a eu
dans les départements pour la série 2020
alors 34 départements scrutin et
nominaux certains ont été pourvu dès le
premier tour donc n'ont même pas été
concernés par les sujets que nous
évoquons si ce n'est sur la publicité
des résultats ils seront à 18 pour la
série à venir en 2023 et sur projection
assez singulière et Madame la mise vous
le rappeliez également puisque c'est la
seule élection nous connaissons de Tours
en une seule journée et que peut-être
effectivement
la proposition de loi de 2019 notre
collègue Alain Richard qui visait
finalement harmonisé s'étend de campagne
précédent les 24 ou 48 heures de
l'élection ont inclus de fait
ce scrutin qui ne peut répondre au même
cadre on peut peut-être s'interroger
tout de même sur la nécessité de
rétablir effectivement un véritable
temps de campagne et je voudrais dire
Madame la Ministre j'entends les
recommandations que vous faites mais
s'il y a certainement un temps très
politique c'est bien un entre-deux tours
puisque c'est la phase ultime après que
que ce temps soit très politique dont le
respect des pratiques républicaines et
des différents candidats avec une chose
mais je crois que ce serait un peu pieux
que d'envisager un deuxième tour qui ne
soit pas politique
que ça qui fait vivre la démocratie et
donc je le disais je crois que si nous
nous rétablissons et sécurisons
finalement la reconnaissance par cette
proposition de loi d'un temps de
campagne de l'entre-deux-tours
il nous demeure encore je crois à
continuer de travailler à nous
interroger sur le formaliser davantage
qu'un simple parallélisme des formes
avec d'autres types de deuxième tour
vous avez évoqué monsieur le rapporteur
et j'aurais une question peut-être assez
précise l'intégration du coup dans des
dans les contes de campagne des dépenses
liées à ce deuxième tour est-ce que l'on
est sur une situation
qui part paralysme des formes voient
finalement le compte du candidat
augmenté dès lors qu'il est qualifié au
deuxième tour est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on
reprend des comptes est-ce que on ne
différencie pas et donc le candidat qui
est au deuxième tour doit intégrer ses
dépenses dans un équivalent de premier
tour et dans ce cas-là ce qu'il n'y a
pas quand même une inégalité entre des
candidats qui ont un compte de campagne
pour un seul tour et des candidats qui
auraient la même somme pour faire un
premier et un deuxième tour même si en
disant cela tout le monde sait très bien
que ces dépenses sont forcément plus
réduites au vu du nombre d'heures qui
sont offertes au candidats mais je crois
que voilà au-delà de cette proposition
de loi qui vise à sécuriser cela
demeure encore sur le long terme
certainement des ajustements à faire et
puis une petite remarque parce que je la
partage en soi comme une remarque quoi
comme étant de bon sens sur l'heure de
publicité des résultats
faisons attention cependant oui la
publicité des résultats c'est toujours
un problème c'est-à-dire qu'il y a plein
de communes ou sur plein de scrutins on
a fini dépouiller à 19h15 je suis pas
certaine que la publicité de ces
résultats là est un impact qui
transformerait tout autre élection et
pour autant
la règle du code électoral veut que on
attendent la fermeture du dernier bureau
de vote en métropole pour pour
communiquer donc l'élection sonartoriale
est particulière mais faisons tout de
même avec prudence toutes dérogation à
l'ensemble du code des électorales sauf
à remettre en cause tous les principes
de notre code électoral et qui garantit
quand même aux yeux de nos concitoyens
la sincérité du scrutin voilà ce que je
veux dire par là c'est pas parce que
l'élection sénatoriale ne concerne que
des grands électeurs et qu'une partie du
de nos de nos concitoyens que nous ne
pouvons que trop facilement voilà
prendre des dérogations avec le
l'ensemble du code électoral qui
s'applique à toutes les élections
merci Madame Goulet
partie des 18 au scrutin majoritaires
donc je vois un peu la question
il y a des traditions dans des
départements ruraux notamment les
conseillers départementaux invitent les
maires à déjeuner et ensuite si un
deuxième tour ils font campagne
eux-mêmes s'agissant des candidats
mon expérience montre que si vous bougez
une oreille entre midi et deux tours
vous avez perdu le deuxième tour donc si
vous voulez la question de la
communication se passe pas exactement de
la même façon dans un département rural
où les mers savent très bien ce qu'ils
ont à faire et où toute communication
inopportunes au moment du calva risque
de leur de les détourner de
lesquels va ou autre risque de les
détourner de leur mission essentielles
pour le deuxième tour non parce que si
vous voulez vous avez non mais le sujet
est quand même sérieux et c'est pas
parce que on est dans une dans une
procédure restreint qu'il faut pas
l'évoquer mais si vous voulez la façon
dont vous décrivez des élections suite à
majoritaires dans un département rural
et est tellement l'ivresse qui est
théorique que ça suscite quand même un
certain nombre de frayeurs de la part
des candidats potentiels parce que on
fait comment avec les conseillers
départementaux qui ont l'habitude de
déjeuner entre les deux tours on fait
comment du conseil départemental qui
envoie une liste de suggestions à ces
conseils départementaux qui envoient une
série de textos au directeur de cabinet
du département qui fait campagne pour le
candidat qui soutient etc tout ça pose
un certain nombre d'autres difficultés
qui qui n'ont rien à voir avec le
caractère totalement théorique de ce que
vous êtes en train d'expliquer pour
lequel vous avez absolument raison donc
sur ces sujets là il faudra quand même
être extrêmement prudent de façon à ce
que un texte qui se veut être un texte
de protection un texte de clarification
ne ne retourne pas contre les candidats
parce que c'est quand même de ça dont on
est en train de parler parce que on va
inscrire des règles plus strictes que ce
que
des règles adaptées aux scrutin
majoritaire ce que je comprends très
bien mais dès que vous allez toucher des
comptes de campagne sur un sujet sur
lesquels les candidats maîtrisent pas
forcément la chaîne des opérations entre
le car qui est loué par une
intercommunalité pour amener tous les
grands électeurs à la préfecture ou à
l'endroit où se passe les élections dans
lequel évidemment il y a une
communication qui se fait dans le car
parce que comme ça tous les mers
arrivent ensemble et ils votent bien au
bon moment etc enfin tout ça risque de
poser des problèmes de compte de
campagne et risque à mon sens de se
retourner contre les candidats si les
précisions sont pas vraiment extrêmement
synthétiques et extrêmement clair donc
voilà moi je voulais quand même attirer
votre attention sur le fait que la
partie liée au compte de campagne devait
être extrêmement rigoureuse dans son
énoncé merci merci Monsieur Marc merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le Président aujourd'hui autour
de la proposition de loi et Monsieur le
reporter mes chers collègues je suis
aussi de le département où nous sommes
deux sénateurs et mais je ne suis pas
concerné par la prochaine élection
simplement c'est vrai que quand
j'entends bien évidemment je suis pour
cette proposition de loi mais je rejoins
les propos de Nathalie Goulet je crois
que ça se passe pas du tout comme vous
pensez que cela se passe pour ceux qui
ont des gros départements avec beaucoup
de grands électeurs c'est quelque chose
de tout à fait pas étrange mais j'ai eu
la chance de passer au premier tour mais
j'ai assisté j'ai assisté j'ai assisté à
des intro de Tours j'ai assisté à des
entre-deux-tours ou évidemment comment
on fait les divers grands électeurs sont
répartis dans les restaurants de la
ville alors on va aller voir les uns et
les autres les SMS ça marche à fond etc
donc
qu'elle va qu'elle va être que le monde
d'être les formes de cette propagande
qui va être autorisée c'est ça qui
compte parce qu'en réalité vous pouvez
aussi si vous en avez
400 ou 500 vous pourriez à la limite
proposer à chacun indigestif vous voyez
je vais jusqu'au bout de l'absurde mais
presque et ce qui pourrait bien
évidemment faire un être des recours
juridiques ensuite donc il faut être
prudent en la matière depuis que
évidemment il faut que les sénateurs
remettent aussi des comptes de campagne
des choses sont en train de de s'affiner
mais je vous le dis ça se passe pas
comme vous aussi simplement que ce que
l'on croit je rejoins les propos de
Nathalie il faudra vraiment préciser des
choses en termes de propagande
merci
juste je me permets peut-être j'ai
encore beaucoup de demandes de paroles
6 je me permets simplement de vous
rappeler que nous sommes en législation
en commission et donc tout est
retransmis donc faites attention quand
même sur certains points
je ne bride pas la parole mais je
j'allerte monsieur Kerrouche
président
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
oui je pense qu'il faut qu'on revienne
au débat de la de la PPL en tant que tel
alors peut-être que dans les Landes
parce que je suis concerné aussi par ce
mode d'élection c'est marocaine roll que
dans l'Aveyron ou dans l'Orne mais
la proposition par d'un fait tout simple
c'est que l'élection l'élection
sénatoriale est la seule qui fait que
une assemblée est élue par deux modes de
scrutin différents et ça explique en
fait une grande partie des dispositions
y compris d'ailleurs en termes de en
termes de publicité il s'avère que
l'article l'article 49
en s'appliquant aux élections et si je
me souviens bien au moment de la loi de
décembre 2019 cette extension s'est fait
par amendement sans que l'on s'interroge
sur la portée éventuelle de ces de ces
amendements parce que ça semblait de
s'assembler de bon sens or il s'avère
que et
cette application a été
dysfonctionnelle en 2020 et si on
revient au cœur de la PPL moi ce que je
comprends c'est que surtout celle-ci
veut éviter des recours qui ont déjà eu
lieu et qui pourrait compliquer
largement la situation
au moment de de ces élections il est
évident que dans le recours qui a été
fait auprès du Conseil constitutionnel
pour le département de la Haute-Saône si
ma mémoire est exacte le Conseil
constitutionnel a juger que
la différence de voix permettait de
comprendre qu'il y ait eu
processus électoral on va dire entre les
deux tours malgré que normalement suite
à la loi de 2019 se n’aurait pas dû être
le cas il nous appartient de ne pas
multiplier ce genre de difficultés
maintenant quelle est qu'elle est
identifiée par ailleurs effectivement
au-delà de l'image d'Épinal il y a
toujours eu un processus électoral
particulier entrée de deux tours d'une
élection à scrutin une inominale
majoritaire pour les départements
concernés ça fait partie
d'un folklore électoral mais qui mais
qui existe encore faut-il le codifier et
faire en sorte que on évite en effet les
difficultés et c'est pour ça que en ce
qui concerne notre groupe nouveau tronc
à la fois la proposition qui est faite
et également l'amendement la proposition
parce qu'elle corrige l'aspect principal
s'agissant de la publicité des élections
et bien là aussi
la différence de communication est liée
à la différence de scrutin et on imagine
mal que des scrutins qui soient déjà
officiels localement ne soient pas
communiquer nationalement donc on part
d'une régularisation et il nous semble
aussi que l'amendement du rapporteur en
matière en matière financière vient
justement donner une précision
nécessaire voilà merci
merci
des demandes de parole de Monsieur
watteblée Madame canailler Monsieur
Bonhomme monsieur Richard et Madame
bellurou donc c'est la parole à Monsieur
va te blend merci maman je vais
simplement c'est une proposition qui me
paraît logique puisque toute élection
entre deux tours il y a une campagne
entre deux sauf qu'on se retrouve dans
un problème de temps donc moi je suis
favorable avec cette proposition de loi
par contre je voudrais mettre comme des
des guillemets sur les dépenses
on devrait encadrer les pensées par
rapport au poste total parce que
imaginez un candidat qui a pas fait de
dépenses et qui sortent de Tours je mets
le paquet comme on dirait pour voilà
donc il faut quand même par rapport à
l'enveloppe générale de la campagne sur
un pourtant pour dépenses limité par
rapport ce temps des détours faut pas
qu'il y ait un excès inverse je prends
un exemple j'ai une campagne je ne pense
pas beaucoup puis je mets quelque chose
d'important entre deux tours je les axe
tout donc je pourrais quand même
encadrer ce côté là de même qu'en
matière de publicité si une publicité
qui doit être faite entre deux tours il
faut l'encadrer par rapport au général
je pense que j'ai des critères là sont
importants on rentre d'un logique de
toute campagne de tours mais l'encadrer
très fortement pour qu'il n'y ait pas
d'excès parce que ce qui va nous être
rocher c'est excès qu'on aura pour
certains candidats
merci Madame canaillé oui madame la
Présidente très rapidement j'aurais
profité de ce texte qui est plein de bon
sens et qui permet d'encadrer encore
mieux ces élections centrales et je
pense que tout ce qu'il va dans un va
dans le sens d'un encadrement et qui
contribue à faire en sorte que cette
élection soit considérée comme une
véritable élection avec ses
particularités mais au même niveau que
les autres élections démocratiques est
un va dans le bon sens j'en profite pour
attirer l'attention madame la ministre
sur l'organisation même de ces élections
et la nécessité d'accompagner ou
transmettre aux préfectures les moyens
pour véritablement organiser dans des
bonnes conditions je reviens sur les
sénatoriales dans mon département la
Seine-Maritime en 2020 sans vous dire
que les mères ont fait deux heures et
demi queue sous la pluie et que il y a
eu un dépouille le dépouillement terminé
à 21h le soir
et qu'on a même eu les excuses du préfet
tellement c'était mal organisé et que
c'était le grand bazar parce que moi
l'expression et si ça qu'une seule fois
en 2020 on aurait pu dire donc tac mais
c'était déjà une redite de 2014 donc
s'il vous plaît madame la ministre
passez des messages que ce sont de vrais
élections dans les communes quand on a
des corps électoraux je parle là aussi
de ma commune sans 4000 avec 144 bureaux
on arrive à organiser correctement et
c'est vrai que dans les préfectures pour
les élections sertiales c'est souvent
pas le cas
merci Monsieur Bonhomme
oui merci Madame Présidente je crois
qu'il faut d'abord je souscris
pleinement aux propositions
de son initiateur je pense vraiment
qu'il est important de de dire d'abord
que le scrutin sénatorial est un
secrétaire particulière en raison de
laquelle raison des de ce qui a été
avancé c'est-à-dire la courte amplitude
horaire entre le premier second tour
dans le même jour donc c'était
singularité doit vraiment être prise en
compte pour ne pas uniformiser
les réglementations internes électorales
ensuite effectivement il faut avoir en
tête la
l'égalité des candidats et tenir la
possibilité que que les candidats
puissent diffuser des tracts
tenir des réunions voir introduire des
éléments nouveaux de propagande avec
la possibilité de laisser de répondre
dans un laps de temps aussi court pose
d'énormes difficultés donc les candidats
à cette élection doivent savoir à quoi
s’entretenir et c'est extrêmement
difficile parce que quand tu arrives
aujourd'hui scrutin souvent on est pris
au dépourvu on est pris au dépourvu
devant le flou relatif qui qui préside à
ce type d'élection donc la clarification
et la sécurité qui est proposée est
vraiment bienvenue je me fais pas tout
pour autant trop d'illusions il restera
un flou qui va donner lieu à
nécessairement à des recours et que seul
la commission nationale déconne de
campagne au jus d'élection sera même de
clarifier parce qu'on n'a pas encore
loin de là tout à fait clarifié et je
dois dire on n'a pas tout à fait
aujourd'hui la totalité des réponses aux
questions qui peuvent se poser
merci Monsieur Richard
d'autant plus modeste que si on les
faits aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'il y
avait une imperfection dans la
proposition de loi que j'avais présenté
il y a maintenant 4 ans avec une large
approbation des races au travail de
collectif de la commission enfin nous
avons nous avions encore raté
un ou deux détails donc comment plus le
Torino qui s'occupe de mes cordes
vocales m'a demandé de ne pas parler
beaucoup je vais être particulièrement
sobre mais je voudrais souligner que il
fallait en effet faire cette proposition
de régularisation pour fixer le cadre
légal
de ce que peut-être ce que peut être une
campagne entre les deux tours
mais il faut aussi j'entends certaines
interventions rappeler ce que sont ce
qu'est le cadre le principe de toute
campagne électorale et le premier
élément de ce cadre c'est la liberté
d'expression des candidats avec
contrepartie un contrôle qui ne peut
être que celui du juge quant à la
loyauté de l'expression des uns et des
autres et en particulier la le non accès
à des arguments qui peuvent être
diffamatoires et la possibilité pour la
personne mise en cause de répondre donc
tout ceci s'applique et s'applique déjà
aujourd'hui dans le cadre chronologique
très étroit de la campagne
d'entre-deux-tours et ça appelle
naturellement les candidats à la
prudence et moi j'approuve le
gouvernement comme la fou comme l'ont
fait d'ailleurs les gouvernements
antérieurs depuis longtemps
de rappeler ces principes de base pour
les candidats qui peuvent ne pas avoir
forcément assimiler l'ensemble du schéma
avant le avant l'élection et je suis mis
en particulier un risque qui existe dans
toute l'élection et qui sera encore plus
prononcé dans ce cette campagne licite
d'entre eux c'est que doivent être à la
charge en tant que dépense de campagne
d'un candidat toutes les dépenses
engagées à son profit et donc pas
forcément par lui-même
donc ceci est une règle permanente
devant laquelle évidemment tout candidat
doit ouvrir le maximum de parapluies
mais il peut toujours être pris en
défaut de ce côté-là et enfin j'en
profite pour répéter suivant le principe
des trompettes de Jéricho au
gouvernement qu'il faut refondre le code
électoral qui est un document juridique
périmé et en désordre qui n'est plus
maniable donc il y a une commission
supérieure de codification pour ça il
faut la faire travailler
merci et enfin Madame belureau merci
madame la Présidente juste pour rebondir
sur les propos de Nathalie et Dalin
concernant les scrutins majoritaires à
deux tours en effet on est peu nombreux
mais il n'en demeure pas moins que c'est
un peu plus spécifique et si ce texte
est adopté ce que je souhaite suite à
l'excellent travail du de l'auteur et du
rapporteur il serait bon que dans les
décrets d'application évidemment dans le
respect de la loi mais que les décrets
d'applications puissent aussi être écrit
en ayant une consultation des sénateurs
qui sont concernés parce que ils ont une
pratique et il ne faudrait pas que c'est
décret viennent mettre à mal la
situation que nous connaissons dans nos
élections sénatoriales merci
merci je clos la discussion générale je
laisse la parole à Monsieur le
Rapporteur s'il a quelques précisions à
apporter ensuite peut-être aussi à
madame la ministre si elle veut
s'exprimer rapidement je
rappelle simplement que la séance
commence à 10h30 donc si nous pouvons
terminer notre
commission à 10h30 ce serait parfait
monsieur le rapporteur merci madame le
Président
juste quelques quelques mots pour
répondre à notre collègue Cécile Kerman
effectivement on n'est pas dans la
logique des municipales où il y a un
plafond par partout en fonction du
nombre du nombre d'habitants
c'est très clair il y a un seul comme de
compagne il y a des plafonds de dépenses
et tout le monde les maîtrise un 10000
euros par candidat ou par liste avec une
majoration de 0,05 euros par habitant
du département pour les départements et
lisant deux sénateurs au moins ou 0,02
euros par habitant du département pour
les départements et disons trois
sénateurs ou plus donc la philosophie
est clairement inscrite dans le cadre
législatif et effectivement vous l'avez
noté le temps de la campagne entre le
premier et le second tour est quand même
très restreint peut-être que ça poserait
des problèmes de philosophie si
dorénavant un jour on est on a un second
tour une semaine après le premier tour
pour répondre
à notre collègue à la marque
la proposition de loin
déjà il y a une dérogation par rapport à
l'interdiction posée par l'article L49
et ses interdictions sont très très
précises et très ciblées il y en a
quatre c'est l'envoi de messages
électronique la réunion électorale la
distribution de bulletins et des appels
téléphoniques en série donc en fait les
modalités de campagne sont déjà
clairement définies par rapport à
l'article L49
s'agissant de notre collègue de Monsieur
kerouche effectivement il a il a
pleinement raison il y a une seule
décision du Conseil constitutionnel
suite aux élections
sénatoriales de 2020 et cette décision
du Conseil
elle a considéré qu'un déjeuner avec des
grands électeurs
peut-être assimilé à une réunion
électorale donc forcément c'est une
irrégularité
car maintenant l'article L49 je précise
on est dans le scénario 2020 néanmoins
l'écart en espèces les quarts de voie
étaient tel et vous l'avez souligné que
la le Conseil constitutionnel a
considéré que la sincérité du du scrutin
n'avait pas été altéré donc l'élection
n'a pas été annuée pour autant pour
autant le risque juridique existait vous
allez bien dans le cadre d'un scénario
où il y avait un écart très faible je
pense que la décision du Conseil
constitutionnelle était tout autre
par rapport à notre collègue enfin
Monsieur watermel
les règles actuelles de plafonnement des
dépenses électorales chez l'article
l308-1 permettent d'ores et déjà
d'encadrer les montants de dépenses
engagées effectivement c'est au candidat
de gérer sa campagne en fonction du
premier et de second tour et de garder
entre guillemets une poire pour la soif
pour pas clairement déplafonnés ou en
tout cas ne pas respecter le plafond et
cette pépl n'aurait pas pour conséquence
de monter le plafond actuel ça a été
rappelé suite à l'intervention de Madame
cukermann voilà ce que je voulais dire
clairement et sachant qu'il y a beaucoup
de pédagogies je pense à faire au niveau
des candidats et à travailler notamment
le guide que le ministère de l'Intérieur
va rédiger
notamment de bien préciser que c'est
bien une réouverture
de la période de la propagande
électorale entre le 1er second tour et
nullement le samedi ou le dimanche matin
pour pas qu'il y ait de là aussi de
troubles et de dépenses engager le
samedi parce que on aurait soi-disant
dit clairement que le premier second
tour on rouvre tout donc ça aussi il y a
une sorte de clarification et beaucoup
de pédagogie à faire au niveau des
candidats à travers le guide notamment
merci monsieur le rapporteur je vais
laisser la parole à madame la ministre
si elle souhaite répondre et je vois que
vous avez été quand même largement
sollicitée à la fois par le rapporteur
mais également par nos collègues
sénateurs afin de rédiger j'allais dire
un guide très précis et peut-être mis à
jour merci oui je serais extrêmement
brève parce que je suis attendue comme
vous je pense à la demi donc juste vous
dire que j'ai tout noté donc le guide
bien sûr mais aussi votre appel
à une organisation sans faille dans les
préfectures donc c'est noté bien sûr des
décrets d'application écrit en
concertation et les sénateurs donc j'ai
pris bonne note des choses concrètes
pragmatiques à court terme et je vous
remercie vous avez raison de le dire à
court terme puisqu'on compte sur vous
pour le pour que cette proposition de
loi
soit définitivement adoptés dans les
meilleurs délais alors je vais posséder
au je vais faire voter l'article premier
qui est il y a l'amendement est après
l'article premier donc on va d'abord
l'article premier donc qui est pour
l'article premier vous avez des
délégations de vote
qui est contre
qui s'abstient merci maintenant monsieur
rapporteur si vous voulez présenter
votre amendement
utile de rappeler le périmètre puisque
il n'y a plus lieu de faire des
amendements pour le passage en séance
donc voilà pardon oui on l'a déjà évoqué
longuement dans le cadre de la
discussion générale c'était le moment
elle vise vise tout simplement à adapter
la rédaction de l'article 52-4 du code
électoral afin d'assurer l'éligibilité
au remboursement des dépenses de
campagne engager par les candidats aux
élections sénatoriales entre les deux
tours d'un scrutin dans sa rédaction
actuelle l'article l52-4 exclu des
dépenses éligibles au remboursement
les dépenses intervenants le jour même
du scrutin or on l'a vu les candidats
aux élections sénatoriales qualifiées
pour le second tour sont susceptibles
d'engager des dépenses le jour même du
scrutin c'est à dire entre les deux
tours
et donc cette modification vise à
inclure ses dépenses dans le champ des
dépenses éligibles chouette quand même
souligner un point qui est assez
important parce que même si l'article
est de 52-4 s'applique à l'ensemble des
élections et pas uniquement aux
élections sénatoriales la modification
proposée n'aurait aucune incidence dans
les faits sur le financement des
dépenses électorales des candidats aux
élections
sénatoriales
en effet pour toutes les autres
élections que les élections sénatoriales
les articles l47a et L49 s'applique donc
toute action de propagande menée dans le
cadre des autres élections et qui
interviendrait en fait le jour même de
l'élection seront donc considérés comme
illégal au regard des dispositions des
deux articles précités je pense que
c'était important de le préciser et
peut-être pour faire suite à la remarque
de Monsieur Richard les dépenses
engagées pour le compte également du
candidat
absolument
la commission seule la commission
apprécie
les dépenses
[Musique]
merci je madame la Présidente je vais
raccourcir mon propos pour simplement
vous dire que cette mesure vient porter
une souplesse dans la définition de la
période prise en compte pour le recueil
des dépenses engagées en vue d'une
élection elle permet uniquement pour les
élections sénatoriales ou l'articles L49
est retenu inapplicable par la
proposition de prendre en compte
éventuel dépenses électorales engagées
entre les deux tours période qui est
nécessairement le même jour que le
scrutin c'est le cas par exemple pour
les déjeuner électoraux entre les deux
tours de scrutin cette proposition
n'entraîne pas de conséquence pour les
autres scrutins car en effet l'article
L49 du code électoral interdit toute
campagne électorale le jour du scrutin
ce qui empêche que des dépenses puissent
être inscrites au compte de campagne
pour l'ensemble de ces motifs le
Gouvernement émet un avis favorable à
cet amendement relatif à la modification
de l'article l52-4 du code électoral
permettant la prise en compte du cas
spécifique de l'entre-deux-tours des
élections sénatoriales sans atteindre
l'équilibre général et l'esprit de la
disposition garantissant la sincérité
des opérations électorales merci madame
la ministre je pense que comme nous
avons nous avons pu nous exprimer en
discussion générale je vais passer au
vote directement de l'amendement qui est
pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté merci donc
maintenant je vais faire voter l'article
2 qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté et maintenant je fais voter
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi qui
est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient et bien
écoutez c'est un grand succès merci à
l'auteur et au rapporteur et rendez-vous
en séance merci